the Harry Potter films were perfectly
cast but it's still fun to look at what
might have been especially when it comes
to actors who decided to pass on the
chance to participate in such a huge
blockbuster here are some actors who
decided that appearing in the Wizarding
franchise just wasn't for them
Ian McKellen is a legendary actor so it
makes sense that his name came up to
replace Richard Harris as Dumbledore in
the wake of Harris tragic death
following the second film however
McKellen turned down the role because he
thought it would have been inappropriate
as he explained people say to me don't
you wish you'd play Dumbledore I say no
I played Gandalf the original there was
a question as to whether I might take
over from Richard Harris but seeing is
one of the last things he did publicly
would say what a dreadful actor he
thought I was it would not have been
appropriate for me to take over his part
it would have been unfair
he played Dumbledore of course the
wizard I paid the real wizard although
Michael Gambon eventually took over the
role for the rest of the series McKellen
still gets confused for the character he
told The Telegraph in 2013 the other day
there were 100 people outside the
theater who wanted autographs just as I
did the last one
a woman grasped my hand and said it's so
wonderful to meet Dumbledore in person I
blew her a kiss and got into my car
Tilda Swinton was set to take on the
part of batty professor Sybill Trelawney
but she ended up turning down the role
at the time it was reported that she
couldn't fit the film into her busy
schedule
however some comments she's made since
then imply that she may have actually
had a much weirder reason in a 2016
interview with Scots magazine Swinton
condemned
boarding schools Hogwarts included she
called her own experience at West Heath
boarding school in London a quote very
lonely and isolating environment she
further explained that's why I disliked
films like Harry Potter which tend to
romanticize such places I think they are
a very cruel setting in which to grow up
and I don't feel children benefit from
that type of Education children need
their parents and the love parents can
provide Emma Thompson ended up with the
part and Swinton avoided having to
relive any bad memories Hugh Grant was
reportedly so prepared to play the role
of Papas defence against the dark arts
professor Gilderoy Lockhart in Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets that
he went ahead and dyed his hair blonde
however
he ended up backing out to star in the
romantic comedy two weeks notice
however Chamber of Secrets director
Christopher Columbus contested these
reports claiming that he had never
spoken to the actor about doing the film
regardless of what grant was or wasn't
offered the part ended up going to
Kenneth Branagh who brought a standard
level of gusto to the performance Pulp
Fiction actor Tim Roth was forced to
decide between Tim Burton's 2001 Planet
of the Apes remake and the part of
Severus Snape and Harry Potter
according to Roth he was offered the
role before Alan Rickman was but he
decided to turn it down so that he could
focus on Apes as he told MTV News in
2007 I was going to do both films we
rigged it so that I could fly back and
forth they figured out the schedule but
it just got to be overwhelming in my
mind my kids really like the books they
were really into me doing it but the
idea of being an ape with Tim was too
good while Rickman was ultimately
incredible in the role Roth might have
been closer to how the books originally
described Snape Rickman was old for the
part at 55 when the first film was
released while broth was only 38 based
on the books Snape should have been 31
when Harry started at Hogwarts according
to Roth he would have played Snape very
differently but he ultimately believed
Rickman was the right man for the role I
didn't want my life to be franchised
Helen McCrory didn't miss out on the
Harry Potter films entirely but she was
kept from playing a much bigger part
than what she ended up with McCrory
ultimately played Narcissa Malfoy though
she was originally cast as narcissus
sister
Bellatrix Lestrange that role eventually
went to Helena Bonham Carter when
McCrory got pregnant you should be
honored Cissy assured Rekha
he's just a boy as McCrory taught Parade
in 2011 I got pregnant with my first
child and insurance wouldn't cover
pregnant witches
it was lovely that they invited me back
and wanted me to be a part of it somehow
this begs the question what are the
maternity leave policies at Hogwarts and
the rest of the Wizarding World fans
started pushing for author JK Rowling to
appear in the Harry Potter films as soon
as they were announced but the writer
says she's better off behind the camera
rolling told The Sunday Mail that
producers offered her the chance to play
Harry's mom Lily but she ultimately
turned them down as she put it I really
am not cut out to be an actress even one
who just has to stand and wave I would
have messed it up somehow
while Geraldine Somerville did a great
job as Lily were sure fans would have
loved Rowling in the part two even if
she did mess it up it would have been a
thrill to see a beloved author do a
cameo check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bells so you don't miss a single one
[Music]